dans cette famille recomposée et des
confiné il y a mathilde est clément les
enfants de sandrine qui vont à l'école
primaire et maternelle de saint germain
de la grange et lucas et nolan les
enfants de laurent qui vont à l'école
primaire de plaisir et au collège de ben
une semaine sur deux la famille passe de
2 à 6
et pour gérer le déconfinement avec des
jours d'école différents selon les
enfants il faut de l'organisation comme
si chez ma mère puisque je suis
prioritaire et mais je vais à l'école
toute la semaine de quatre jours et
quand chez mon père en fait comme une
île est pas prioritaire
je vais une seule fois par semaine et en
plus des trajets différents pour les
amener à l'école il faut gérer les repas
clément tu goûtes aussi devant tu veux
au centre de ce soir tu vas la garderie
où tu auras de ça y'a pas de cantine et
on peut pas réchauffer des plats donc en
fait ces repas froid donc le plus simple
effectivement c'est les sandwichs
difficulté supplémentaire laurent
entamer un nouveau travail
juste avant le confinement il a dû céder
confiné plus tôt dès le 25 avril et
reprendre un rythme complet de 39 heures
petit appétit et repart de plus belle
dans l'organisation et puis c'est vrai
que en tant donné que je ne peux pas
emmener les enfants l'heure actuelle est
que ma femme les gardes peut se
permettre de se mettre en télétravail
les jours où les enfants n'ont pas école
sandrine et donc en télétravail depuis
le confinement à la pris ses habitudes
les enfants font leurs devoirs le matin
et joue l'après midi j'essaye de faire
mon maximum un peu comme général je suis
pas de bruit ou quand je leur dis quand
mon téléphone sonne voilà ne pas faire
trop de bruit à côté alors forcément là
donc de la reprise de l'école le 22 juin
était un soulagement même si tout le
monde s'est bien adapté à ce rythme un
peu chamboulé et un peu ils sont les
jouets achats mais plus d'un mètre en
face et solidaire sur certaines fois un
pied bien sûr chamailleries passage ça
restait la fratrie pour le coup donc
voilà je pense que c'est un bon test
pour nous tous les six partiront en
vacances au camping en france pour se
reposer de tout ça et profiter d'être
ensemble en espérant une rentrée en
septembre plus sereine avant de
s'attaquer à un nouveau projet
nécessitant organisation
le mariage de sandrine et laurent prévu
initialement en mai dernier est
repoussée à l'année prochaine